Everyone, welcome to LED Live. Thanks
for joining us today. Today, we're going
to talk about mindfulness and the
question we want to ask you, is that
science or is it sorcery? Find out on
this episode of LED Live.
Light exposing darkness.
All right, welcome back everyone. Today,
we have a couple of guests with us. We
have Eric Wilson from Isaiah Ministries
and we have Mike Shreve. Remind me of
Good to be here. the name of your
ministry. Shreve Ministries. Shreve
Ministries. Well, that's easy.
How could we How could I mess that up?
Shreve But I also have an outreach to
people who are searching called The True
Light Project. All right, The True Light
Project. We will have information on
both of these gentlemen on the
description below. You can see links
where you can contact them through their
website, see what resources they have in
the form of books or other media. We
also want to thank our patrons who help
support this show. Thank you so much for
making these possible. Uh we also have
other things for you to check out for
our ministry. We have things like
t-shirts. Now, we have a couple of
stickers that we're releasing, so you
want to check those out on our website.
We also don't want to forget our Spanish
channel. We're branching out into
Spanish and putting more content on a
regular basis on the Spanish side of
things. We also have t-shirts, so check
out Teespring for that. Don't forget we
have videos, documentaries on all kinds
of media subjects. You can get those on
our web store or on Vimeo. Once again,
descriptions in the link below. But
today, the topic is mindfulness.
And is that science or is it sorcery?
So, Eric,
Before we get into that though, I I I
want to tell you guys about one of the
post shows that we did.
the post show. And so, we do a post show
for those people that support us on
Patreon and we just It's our way of just
saying thank you so much for keeping the
lights on in our ministry.
And Keith, actually tell them tell them
a little bit about what the post show is
about.
So, the post show is going to take a
look about Disney.
They released something called
Zenimation and so, we're going to take a
look at that. The post show is called
Meditation
or No, it's called When Meditation Meets
Animation. So, you want to check that
out after this program. It's really
interesting to see how the entertainment
industry is ramping up this topic. I
mean, this is why we feel so passionate
to keep coming back and discussing this
whole issue because we not only see it
in pop culture, but I mean, we're
starting to see children, kids getting
introduced to this that they maybe don't
know where the roots of this come from
or even if there's a danger to it. So,
thank you guys for both being on our
show and we're excited to get into this.
It's good to be here. Important. Oh, I
also want to do a plug for for Mike
Shreve's book. Tell them about the book,
Mike. In Search of The True Light is a
comparison of over 20 religions.
And most importantly, I take 30 of the
main doctrines or concepts that most new
agers or people given to a far eastern
religious worldview
believe in and then I respond in a
biblical way or from a biblical
worldview. For instance, there's one
section in there on 13 reasons I no
longer believe in reincarnation. So, we
touch on all the issues that
are very popular in our culture and our
world now because they stem from eastern
religions, Hinduism, Sikhism,
Jainism and so forth. Buddhism, like
we're going to be touching on today. We
had Mike's testimony on here, so if you
haven't seen his testimony, click
through some of our videos in our
YouTube page and you'll get a chance to
hear how he got involved in all this and
why he's even writing books like this.
Yeah, I was a yoga teacher, Kundalini
yoga teacher for universities and
running a yoga ashram. Wow.
With about 300 students who thought I
was their guru. Mhm. And the word guru
means one who brings you out of darkness
into light.
And that's the essence of the meaning of
the two root words. There was a huge
problem. I wasn't in the light yet.
Isn't that interesting? They call it the
light, but they're almost leading you
into more darkness. It's very
interesting.
Jesus said, "Take heed lest the light
that is in you be darkness." So, so some
of us claim to be enlightened,
but it's really a deeper form of
darkness because it carries us deeper
into deception by thinking we're in the
light.
Awesome. Well, thanks guys for showing
up on our show and let's let's turn it
over to you.
I'm I'm very excited to be here and this
this topic, we actually we shared a
little bit on this in a series we did
with a ministry called Secrets Unsealed
last year and I think that one's also
available online on their YouTube
channel.
This one that we're going to be sharing
today, we go much more in depth though.
Because of
Mike and Keith and my background, cuz
Keith was heavily involved in Chinese
kung fu. Mike was, you know, as he said,
an instructor or what they called a guru
in Hindu yoga and I was heavily involved
in martial arts and Chinese key gong. Um
all of those fields all have one thing
in common, meditation.
Um meditation is being brought into our
Christian churches now. They're calling
it all different names, you know, breath
prayers or contemplative prayer.
But you think when I was growing up, you
never saw I mean, like that was like
that was pagan.
That was like a no-no as a Christian,
but now it's like
the water has gotten very muddy. There's
no longer a clear distinction between
right and wrong and light and darkness.
They want everything to be gray.
And you know, so meditation coming in
like with the contemplative, you know,
church and and the emerging church
movement, a lot of that stuff.
Um
but then there's something else that has
sprung out of that and this was
interesting because like you said and
Keith have talked about
Satan will have a deception and when
people finally start exposing it, he'll
go, "Okay, we're just going to repackage
it and give it a new name."
And all of a sudden, people are like,
"No, no, no, no, that's different."
You know, sometimes I'll get emails or
phone calls and people will say, "Well,
what about this?" And I'm like, "Well,
did you not watch the video?"
Instead of just looking at the name and
the package, look at what's inside. Look
at the principles of what's inside
because if you can identify the
principle, it doesn't matter what it's
wrapped up like. If you know what the
thread is, you're like, "I don't care
what that I know what that ingredient
is. I don't need to ask you I don't need
to have a whole book or or documentary
to tell me this is wrong. It's got that
in it."
The screenshot that you're seeing right
now is from Scientific American and I
want you to realize and we're going to
show a number of different pictures of
magazines.
I want you to realize this is not
something on the fringe movement of
those weird people that do those
strange, you know, things or witchcraft.
This is coming in to modern,
you know, literature, uh doctors'
offices. And they asked, "Does
mindfulness really work?" Some
scientists fear the hype is out pacing
the science.
Um
I'm going to show you that it's not
science. There is a science involved,
but it's
it's science falsely so-called, the
Bible says. It's satanic science.
We're going to open with a verse in 2
Corinthians chapter 11, verse 3. And let
me uh
let me just read this to you.
And pay attention to the words. Don't
read your Bible and just skim over. Pay
attention to what's being said.
The Apostle Paul was inspired to write
and he said, "But I fear lest by any
means, just as the serpent beguiled
Eve." That means hypnotized. Eve
through his subtlety.
So, your mind should be corrupted from
the simplicity that is in Christ. And I
want to make a note of that.
Just as the serpent beguiled Eve,
hypnotized. That's what the word means.
Most of us think of a hypnotism of
they're holding a watch or they're
flashing a light, you know, and that
hypnotizes you. Satan was not doing any
of that.
Do you know how he hypnotized her?
Words. With his words.
You know what they call that today?
Neuro-linguistic
NLP. NLP. Neuro-linguistic programming
and it's really interesting. We've done
a couple projects on that on you can
actually change people's minds based on
the type of words that you're throwing
at people. It's It's a really
interesting and fascinating. It's It's
in the hypnosis vein. Yes. But you can
actually control what some outcomes are
literally by your language.
All media study that all the time. I
just looked this up in Strong's. Yeah,
we're about to get there. Don't go there
yet.
Okay. Okay. That's natural on what?
On one of the words in here.
Which word? No, no, no. No, simplicity.
Okay. Well, I was I was going to apply
something on a
I know when I said we were going to go
there.
Amen. You guys are covering simplicity.
I did a word study on um
the word uh subtle in Genesis chapter 3.
And you trace that back
as far as you can, it has
pre-Indo-European
root.
And that word, when you kind of boil it
down, it means to turn.
Like a ship.
Okay? Seafaring vessel or you know, in
modern context it would be a plane or
something like that. You mean like the
slow turn a ship has to make? Well,
yeah, and then you ships don't make a
very fast turn, right? That's a I never
thought of it like that. When I'm
speaking to audiences about that
passage, I'll tell them, "Hey, this is
this is exactly what Satan wants to do
to you is he wants to
turn you."
Because and get you off course. And when
you start out, like if you're if you're
making a journey on an ocean liner or
something,
if you were to alter that course by a
degree, let's say,
you're not going to end up in your
destination, but as you start out,
you're not going to know the difference.
It's going to look like you're going the
right way.
But
The farther down you go where you will
find out where you And that's exactly
what Satan wants to do. He wants to make
it look like you're going the right way,
but you can't tell the difference
and you just find out you've you've
ended up in the wrong place.
And what's interesting about a straight
line is if you go off just one or two
degrees down the road far enough, you
can get a massive distance away from
where you should be simply by a tiny
degree. That illustration is also in
Pilgrim's Progress. Yes, because he's on
he's on the straight and narrow or well,
it's not exactly straight, but it's
narrow, you know, it's rocky and bumpy
and has a few twists and turns in there,
but on the road to despair,
it's grassy and nice and so he decides,
"I'm going to hop off this road cuz it's
kind of rough. I'll get on this other
road because it's parallel. I mean, I
can see where I'm going.
So, how could I, you know, not get to
where I'm supposed to go?" And he stays
on that for a long enough time
that it it veers and he doesn't notice
it. And then he winds up in despair and
the book says it's it's difficult to
escape from despair. Almost nobody gets
out of there. Right.
And that's where he wind up. We call
this the proverbial frog.
You set in the water and it just is a
slow little boil.
So, here
Satan
is deceiving her, beguiling her, but
he's using words. And what hit me with
the the issue of NLP, which is a form of
hypnosis like Scotty said,
I first heard about that in the
religious context. There was warnings
going out about pastors being trained in
this because it's not just controlling
one person. You can use this technique
to influence a large body of people. And
I'm not even going to talk about some of
our former
presidents and things like that, but
it's almost hypnotic how they would get
up and use words and they would move
10,000 people and change the way they
viewed things. Um but what I want to
focus on here is he says
"Just as the serpent beguiled Eve
through his subtlety, so your mind
should be corrupted from the simplicity
that's in Jesus and Christ."
And and I was sitting there reading it
and I was like, "What is that I mean,
why is it What is the simplicity? I
mean, like, you know, I think sometimes
we overcomplicate the gospel.
We add so much to it when he's just
like, "Look, I can distill this down to
a very simple concept."
Well, he took 10 commandments and
reduced them to two commandments. And
and look at what
Love the Lord God with all your heart,
love your neighbor as yourself. Look at
what we do with our laws. I mean, we
have libraries and libraries and
libraries of laws to try to explain
something and God just said, "I can put
10 things down that literally will
illustrate anything you get in trouble
with."
And I'm I'm I'm not disagreeing with
you, but I want to show you something.
There's something deeper there in the
word simplicity.
This is what the word is
in in the original Greek. Simplicity
means singleness,
union,
folded together as one and clear. Wow,
that's beautiful. Now, in the Strong's
that I just referenced, are you going
there?
That Yeah, that's That's the two Greek
words, the the one and then the the root
word. Well, let me show you what else is
said here
is it in the explanation of it, not
the translation of that word, but in the
explanation it says mental honesty.
Mental honesty and I thought that would
fit in well with That does what you're
teaching and does. Yeah. But let me let
me just throw something in there real
quick.
Years ago, we watched a creation science
video. I think it was from Dr. Carl
Ball. And he talked about something that
blew my mind.
He said, "Have you ever wondered in
Revelation why it talks about the
streets being made out of pure gold as
clear as crystal or as clear as glass?"
Yeah, you can see through the gold. I
was like, "You can't see through gold."
And then he talked about something. He
said, "All metals in their purest form
are transparent." And he said, "I can
show you why." He said, "When NASA sent
the space shuttle into outer space, he
said the windshield was coated with gold
and they had to purify it so that it
would be uh transparent. Wow. But the
gold helped protect them from the
radiation and everything that they would
be going through.
Um but then doesn't the Bible say that's
how we're going to be?
As pure gold tried in the fire.
But that's clear, but it also says union
and folded together as one.
You know what you do with a like when I
was in the Eastern arts like in Aikido
and and Kodokan Judo, we did a lot of
training on the samurai and there was a
lot of training with the bokken, the
wooden sword or a katana, which is a
real Japanese, you know, samurai sword.
The way that you got a sword or any
knife uh like a a busse, you know, one
of the best knives in the world. The way
that they make that metal strong is they
take it and they heat it and they fold
it over and they hammer it. And then
they fold it again and hammer it. And
the more times it's folded, the stronger
the metal becomes.
Okay, and there's a reason I'm going
there.
John chapter 17 verse 17 through 21, do
you know what our savior said? He said,
"It is my prayer." His last prayer
before Calvary. He said, "Father, I pray
that they all might be one
in us."
And you people go, "Well, that means
we're going to have union on the way we
believe everything exactly." That's not
what it says. The disciples after
Pentecost didn't agree on everything. I
mean, you remember Paul and who was it?
Was it Timothy or Paul and Mark? Or
Barnabas? They got Yeah, there was some
contention there and
And then you also had contention at the
Jerusalem Council in Acts 15. They were
like, "Well, what about that?" I mean,
the Holy Spirit had fallen. Everybody
didn't see everything exactly the same.
So, there has to be a greater union that
Jesus was asking for. And he says,
"Father, I want them to be one in us as
I am in you and as you are in me."
Now,
that's what God has promised us. And I
want that. I want Christ in me. I want
God in me. I want I want to be filled
with the fullness of the Godhead bodily.
And John chapter 1 says that promise has
been given to us.
Of his fullness have we all received.
Hallelujah.
But let me show you. This is what the
devil's doing to counterfeit.
Now, watch this video.
That was quite a show.
Maybe 10,000 people worshipping,
celebrating,
each gentleman having his own personal
experience with God.
This is clearly
faith in the God in you.
Your inspiration,
your power.
God is so many things to so many people.
The warm light of the sun,
the sound of sweet music,
an inner voice that drives us forward,
a friend.
If you ask me who God is,
I would say there's a bit of the divine
in all of us.
There's God in you. There's God in me.
The God in me
is
who I really am at my core.
The God in me
is the best version of me.
is who I strive to be,
who I was meant to be.
Confío en Buda.
Creo en Dios.
Creo en Jesucristo.
Creo en Dios. Allah. Muchos
piensan distinto,
sienten distinto, buscan a Dios o
encuentran a Dios de diversa manera.
En esta multitud, en este abanico
de religiones,
hay una sola certeza que tenemos para
todos.
Todos somos hijos de Dios.
Creo en el amor.
So wrong.
But that appeals to people.
I'm I'm going to just put a preface here
and I'm not in charge, but I still want
to just do this because we could take 3
hours and just stay right there and and
discuss the problem with what we just
watched. But we don't have 3 hours.
Um
that's what Satan is seeking to do. He's
wanting to counterfeit what Christ is
going to do in his people. Christ said,
"I'm going to make my people one by
putting my presence, my spirit, the
spirit of my father inside of my
people." The devil said, "I'm going to
be like the most high. I will put my
spirit inside my people and we'll see
who wins."
Um
yeah, I don't want to go There's too
much there to go into. There is, but
it's really interesting how Morgan
Freeman came right out of the out of the
gate and if you notice he said, "God is
music to people."
Yeah, that's scary. "This to people. God
is that to people."
Sunshine. The sunshine, right? Sun
worship, all of this.
Right, right. So basically it doesn't
matter what you worship, right? He's
basically illustrating that that is your
God. And And actually, you know what?
That's true. The sun can be your God.
Not the God, not the creator God, but
that can be a god to you. And so to me
that that was him showing his hand right
there. That literally you can make
anything a god. That's why I believe God
literally laid down the very first
commandment. Thou shalt have no other
gods before me because he knew that was
going to be a temptation with all
humanity.
Well, don't you think people confuse
the conscience
which is the only real functional part
of the spirit right now. The spirit is
dead in trespasses and sins except for
the conscience. Uh it has three
functions: communion with God,
revelation from God, and conscience. The
first two are cut off
and the conscience is like a barely
burning ember where there used to be a
raging fire in Adam and Eve.
And they believe that that inner voice
of the conscience is God.
That's a gift from God, but that's not
evidence of the presence of God. And I
try to make that very clear when I teach
on We know we're vessels. We know we can
be empty. We know that we can be filled
with certain things. So, you know, if
you're not filled with the Holy Spirit,
Jesus, you know what I mean? It's like
you can't be filled with something else
and then attribute that to God. Yeah,
Keith had something.
going to say probably the most
disturbing thing about his particular
segment in that was
he was saying that
we are striving to be
the best version of ourselves
and that God is inside of us, but that's
totally bringing God down to
our level.
Yeah, God is not the best version of
myself.
His ways, his thoughts, what he is and
who he is is so much higher
than I can be.
And so to bring that down to my level is
is not right. It's It's disturbing.
that's what we talked about in that
other show where you were pointing out
in Genesis, you know, that's the first
lie of the of the serpent. "You will be
like gods." And we're And it's here. The
end of the world, Christ is about to
return and we're hearing it and we're
hearing it through men and women that
are respected.
You know, I know you don't want to
explore this deeply,
but
but I believe this will leave a huge
question in people's minds that may be
unresolved unless I have a very succinct
way of responding to
And And And if you guys disagree, tell
me. But I had to deal with this when I
wrote my book In Search of the True
Light because that was such a huge
emphasis among New Agers that we are all
children of God. We are all children of
God. And I thought I've got to have a
way of lovingly and logically responding
to that without being insulting
and cut people off from what I have to
say about Jesus. So I prayerfully sought
God for the answer and I realized that
when Jesus instructed large audiences of
people, he would refer to God as their
father. And these people have not been
born again yet. They haven't had the new
covenant transformational regenerative
experience that we know is essential to
be fully a child of God. And yet he
would refer to them as
being in that relationship. He would
say, "Your heavenly father knows that
you have need of these things. Your
heavenly father's good pleasure is to
give you the kingdom." So in their minds
they're thinking, "Well, if he's my
father, I'm his child." And I I realized
that all human beings, and I try to make
this very clear to New Agers,
all human beings are children of God
after the creation,
which is from Adam and Eve onward. But
to be a part of the family of God,
supernaturally and spiritually, you must
be born again.
Because the essential issue and some
apostate Christians, leaders, are
veering from this and they're saying
exactly what Morgan Freeman said, that
God is in everyone. And Is that why it
says we need to be grafted onto the
vine?
Right. Otherwise the vine Yeah, we we're
not just by nature Well, hey, we're part
of the vine, you know what I mean?
We need to actually be grafted onto the
main vine
to be a part of God's family.
several scriptures that make it very
clear that there's a specific moment
when you become uh to as many as
received him, to them gave he power to
become
the sons of God.
Right. So So there's a becoming moment
and Ephesians 3:17 says Christ will
dwell in your heart by faith. So he's
not already there. Which is what I
taught as a New Ager.
Oh, go ahead go ahead. No, I was just
going to say to follow that up, you
know, John 1:12 he is saying he gives
them the right to become children of
God. It follows after that who were born
not of blood. So this is not a physical
creation thing.
Nor of the will of the flesh, nor of the
will of man, but of God. The will of
God.
experience that you're talking about.
And it's not It's not this physical
thing as in yeah, we're all human beings
and we're all God's children in that
sense. It's to become part of the family
of God, you have to be born again. And
just a quick note and this helped me to
I'm glad you brought that out because
that that's essential.
A father is the source
of your of your being. So every human
being that's here is only here because
of God.
But that does not mean like you said
that they are part of the family because
they have alienated themselves through
sin. They they are
cut off because of sin. And God is doing
everything he can to pull us back.
Otherwise it would make no sense. It
would be totally illogical for the
distinction to be made between children
of darkness and children of light,
children of the devil and children of
God. Jesus actually said, "You are of
your father the devil." That would
actually make sense and he cannot lie.
That's not politically correct.
And you know what's scary? He said that
to the church people and the church
leaders in his day. Well, leaders of the
the synagogue. Because they believed I
Hey, I'm born into this Jewish thing and
I'm I'm part of this
Abraham's my father. And they had
Therefore I get the right that Abraham
And they had a form of godliness, but
not the power, which is Christ in us.
So that that is talking
across lines like what we just saw
there. We're talking here is Buddhist
and this, you know, we're still talking
about Jewish people claiming that
they're children of God, which I think
is a you know, a much closer comparison
than doesn't matter what religion you
are. And And how can you mix Buddhism
and Christianity when the basis of
Buddhism is atheism?
Buddha had no set concept of God and
said it was a hindrance to enlightenment
if you explored that. So.
Did you have something, Keith? No, we we
should keep going.
It's good. This is good. Um
let me show you a quote from a Buddhist
author and this is a Caucasian lady, but
she has explored and given her life to
Buddhism. Um the mindfulness controversy
of Buddhism versus psychology. Uh Freud
and Carl Jung talked about these things
as well as Kundalini. They They explored
these things because they were trying to
explore the mind.
But now there has come this controversy
from psychologist of is this just
psychology or is this Buddhism?
Which it came from Buddhism and
Hinduism.
She said in recent years many practicing
psycholo- psychotherapists have adopted
the Buddhist practice of mindfulness as
part of their therapeutic toolkit.
Mindfulness-based stress reduction and
mindfulness-based cognitive therapy, for
example, are being used to treat
conditions such as ADHD, depression,
anxiety, and chronic pain. Isn't that
weird? Mhm. Same thing we learned about
with acupuncture. They almost all of
them said it helps to fix pain.
Mhm.
The results have been enormously
encouraging.
You know, when I look at that and I go,
"Okay, the results were enormously
encouraging,
but where does it come from? What is it
doing?" Mhm. But it's coming into
psychology, and we have been given a lot
of warnings, you know, about the mind.
You don't want somebody getting inside
your head in whatever form. Mhm. Now, I
want to show you just a couple of
uh
magazine covers, a couple of examples of
how this is spreading, how quickly this
is spreading.
Here we see Time magazine, The New
Mindfulness.
Um another one that I've seen in a lot
of health food stores called
Spirituality and Health,
uh Blueprint for the Awakening.
Mhm.
This one was really shocking. This was
Psychology Today.
They said, "Mindfulness is a state of
active, open attention to the present.
That means not looking at the past, at
what happened yesterday, whatever I
failed at or succeeded at, not looking
to the future as in there's any
expectation."
"This state encompasses observing one's
thoughts and feelings without judging
them as good or bad." That is the key.
Mhm. Mindfulness is saying, "There is no
right and wrong. There is no good and
bad. It's just be where you
are. It is what it is,
and that does it it's like situational.
There's no absolutes."
The the pop culture um
world, I don't know, maybe you guys have
seen some Pepsi commercials. They did a
lot of of things where they just said
live for the now. That was their slogan
actually for a while. And so, you know,
there's this idea that it's like, you
know,
you YOLO, you only live once, you know,
it's like today is your day, and and
just, you know, only you do what you
feel is right for you. It's different
for what's right for me, and that whole
kind of post-modernistic thing is
wrapped up into this as well. Moral
relativism. Mhm. So, what we're seeing
here from that cuz I had not seen that
Pepsi commercial. Man, I don't have like
regular television. Mhm. Um
but that means this has been there the
whole time, but now the devil is just
like,
"Let's bring it in a little bit closer.
Let's, you know, it's not a new name cuz
this has been known in the Eastern arts
for a long time, but he's introducing it
to the Western society and Christian
societies." I I want to just share
something real quick. I don't want to
get hung up on this. I was listening to
a pastor um actually yesterday, and he
was telling a story about when he was a
kid, uh
how you know, he got like to scare
people and stuff. And so, when he became
a father, he would always sneak around
the corner, and his kids would walk
around, and he'd scare them, right? So,
then his kids kind of grew up always
trying to scare dad, and they'd they'd
have this little kind of cat and mouse
game.
And he said, "You know, what's
interesting as a parent and you're
older, you know when your kids are going
to try to play a trick on you like this,
right? And when you know what they're
going to do, it's no longer scary to
you."
And so, he was applying that to the book
of Revelation saying, "The reason that
the prophecies are there is because when
you know what's going to happen, it's
not scary to you." And and, you know, I
just kind of thought that was a really
interesting illustration, you know, so
that yeah, it's like if you're telling
people don't look into the future or
don't look into how things have been in
the past, and you're only blinded to it
like the moment right now, you're not
anticipating or seeing what's happening
in the future, and things can catch you
off surprise.
what's weird? I've heard and I've seen
film footage of a lot of the emergent
church leaders that are saying, "We
don't need prophecy. God did not intend
on us to understand prophecy." But
prophecy is like the greatest evidence
that God's word is verily, you know,
true.
And it's the validation of its own
authority. Amen. He says, "I'm the one
that knows the end from the beginning."
Amen. There's no way you could choose
how many civilizations would be the
dominant civilization in the world
thousands of years, you know, before it
happens. That's just impossible. We
don't even know what's going to happen
in the next 10 years.
I'm going to go on just with this one
quote. This is from Psychology Today.
They say, "To live mindfully is to live
in the moment
Mhm. and to reawaken oneself
to to what? Mhm. To like you're asleep?
Yeah, to reawaken oneself to the present
Mhm. rather than dwelling on the past or
anticipating the future.
Mindfulness can also be, they say, a
healthy way to identify and manage
latent emotions that are causing
problems in personal or professional
relationships. What you're doing is is
God convicts us of sin. Mhm. He doesn't,
you know, want us to live in
condemnation, but he convicts us through
his spirit. So, if I'm never examining
my own thoughts, my own emotions, my own
actions as whether they be right or
wrong, you're silencing the voice of God
to the conscience or to your heart,
however he's speaking to you, you cut
off that. Mhm. Yeah. And you never see
your need of Jesus. Amen. But don't you
think there is
a mixture there?
That there is an element of value
in being very cognizant of the inner
workings of your mind and your emotions
so that you can decipher the triggers
that make you angry at someone when you
should be more calm. Yes, and so So,
that's the inroad that it expands to
things that are not right, but the
inroad is well, it's like in
Scientology,
the reason people think Scientology is
effective is it makes them evaluate the
inner workings of their mind uh so that
they can become a quote-unquote clear.
And uh and so, people assume because
this makes me a little bit better person
in my actions and reactions, then it
must be right. And they embrace the
whole package.
found though, and this is and I
understand when
the Bible says, "Let this mind be in me
which was in Christ Jesus." As I claim
that promise in the morning on my knees,
I say, "Lord,
I'm yielding. My body is a vessel to
you. Let this my
His mind, his spirit directs me." So, I
say, "Lord, if I've if I've if there's
examine me like King David said, see if
there be any wicked way in me." And as I
ask him to do that all throughout the
day, he does the examination. So, now
it's not me taking a human perspective
or a psychological perspective of I need
to look at myself. I'm allowing the Lord
to do it, and he brings it to my mind,
and he's like, "Eric, man, you just
talked to that person. You shouldn't
have done that." Or Eric, "You were just
a little bit
rude with your mom. You ought to call
her back." And Eric, "You did this." And
as I as I do that and I yield, he does
that work inside of me, and then I don't
have to worry about the gray areas of
where the enemy might might try to lead
me astray. I think there's always an
element of truth mixed with error. I
think it's always
That's what makes it powerful.
it's always the closer it is to the
truth, the harder it is to detect
because, I mean, correct me if I'm
wrong, right? We are asked to meditate
on the word of God, right? So, you're
kind of using this this word that we're
so we're supposed to sit and think and,
you know, mull over what the word of God
is telling us and everything is, but
it's just like this kind of
different just slightly off-course
meditation.
what makes it powerful to use the same
word to mean a different concept.
good point. And the word is supposed to
convict you of sin. Mhm. It's supposed
to tell you
you know, like Eric was saying, what you
did was right or wrong, not for you to
be in that moment and say, "I have no
judgments." Right. Right. Yeah.
Here's two more slides. National
Geographic there on the left.
Everyday Mindfulness, Finding Focus,
Calm, and Joy. Like you talked about in
our previous, you know, program, people
are searching for healing, especially
emotional healing. Um so, if the
emotional healing can happen, a lot of
times that can be attached to physical
healing. If somebody, and this is
common, um especially with Christians, a
lot of people that have struggled with
um cancer, not everybody. I'm and be
clear on that. Many of them have got
bitterness or some wound to the heart
that has never been healed. So, they're
going to church, and they've got the
written word, and they they don't have a
connection they feel with God. So, when
somebody comes along and says, "I know
what's wrong. I can fix that. If you do
this, you know, if you meditate, if you
do this experience or yoga or tai chi or
whatever, watch what it'll do to the
body. And there is a a thing that
happens there. And then they're they're
trapped. They're the the trap has
sprung.
There's another one here called Living
Now, Demystifying
Meditation. I'm just using these as an
example.
I just got to point this out once again.
It's just interesting observing the
language that's used that they're going
this is mystical. Like it's like really
hard to understand, but we're going to
we're going to tell you a little bit
about what it is. Like that's kind of an
alarm bell to me. Yeah, and I I didn't
even see that. You're right. It says
mindful technology. So they're
there's a blending. This spiritualism is
coming in in all sorts of forms.
Meditate or med-
Or meditate.
Meditate or medicate. The benefits of
Yin Yoga.
All on that one magazine called Living
Now.
This is being used in corporations
heavily to help with because of high
stress levels. You know, I tell people
when they call and they're like, "What
do I do about stress?" I'm like, "If
you're sitting at your office, have a
Bible on your desk and open it up for 5
minutes and read Psalms. And find a
Psalm that is praise and joy. He
promises the joy of the Lord is your
strength. But you have to believe it."
I've had a lot of conversations with
Keith,
you know, and just really focusing on
the promises of God. You know, and just
really like, you know, just if you if
you're feeling down, you just go and
gravitate to the promises that God gives
and it's just like that will just lift
your spirit.
Do you know how many are in the Bible?
I would guess 7,487.
Mhm. Wow.
And there's 31,173
verses. Wow.
a little bit depending on uh certain
views, but uh Wow. So that's about 1/4
of the word of God.
Wow. An old an old an old pastor that
that I've got some CDs from and you can
look it up online. Um his name was Glenn
and he wrote a book called the ABCs
of Bible Prayer and I think his number
was almost exactly. He said, "This is
how many promises there are in God's
word."
Mhm. So if you know, if you're looking
for that, that's a great book. Bible uh
ABCs of Bible Prayer and you can look up
Glenn you know, his series online.
I have a book called 25 powerful
promises from God. Amen.
Love it. Amen. Didn't want to throw that
in. No, you never know.
We'll put a link to that in the
description below. Now, I want to that
brings something up.
Morgan Freeman was talking about us all
being gods. Do you know what the Bible
says in 2 Peter 1:4? Whereby have been
given unto us exceeding great and
precious promises that by these promises
we are made partakers of the divine
nature. Right. A lot of people look at
it and they go, "Oh, it means I'll be in
character, my char- Character and nature
are two different words in the Greek.
Mhm. That's a good point.
Right.
Being a partaker of Christ's character
is essential, but that's not what the
word nature means.
Nature and character are two different
things. You can have two dogs. They have
canine nature.
One dog is hateful and ugly and the
other dog is kind and loving and
protecting, but they have canine nature.
The divine nature is this.
Deity does not sin.
Deity does not die because the wages of
sin is death. Do you know what the Bible
says in 1 John 3:9?
We will get to the place by faith in his
word, you will not sin because God's
word remains in you.
That's a promise. And that's I mean,
that's why David said, you know, let me
hide this in my heart so that That I may
not
sin against you. Love that verse. If
you're if if you're taking this Morgan
Freeman viewpoint, you know, God is your
best self.
What are you going to promise yourself?
That's a good point.
Right. You know, what are you going to
fulfill? What are you going to make
happen? Because he's saying, you know,
it's it's our best self and it's saying,
"Well, you haven't even gotten there
yet." That's a good point. So many
people into the New Age mindset uh
emphasize gratitude. But some of them
that don't even have a concept of God
still emphasize gratitude. Being
grateful for this in your life, being
grateful for that in your life. Grateful
to who? That's Yeah. Just grateful in a
general sense, not toward any creator,
but just grateful. Uh
and I'm sure that makes a person a nicer
person and a
more peaceful person, but it's not a
good enough connection. Amen. You Amen.
You need to know the source of blessing.
Yep. But uh give you the peace that
passes all understanding. Amen.
So corporate mindfulness, they say it's
taking wellness a step farther. These
were two magazines that are actually
titled Mindful and I want to show you
this because these are not like hippie
type people that are, you know, living
out in the outskirts or in the
wilderness. These are are people that
have got class with the world would say
or they have money. They have influence.
Um
some of the other people that you're
going to see here on these screens, like
this gentleman,
um
he's talking about how the Seattle
Seahawks, their coach Pete Pete Carroll
is using mindfulness to change his team.
Interesting. I have seen over and over
again now we're seeing sports stars that
are saying
Tom Brady. I saw an interview with him
and they were like, you know, "What are
you doing? What makes you win out there
on the field?" He was like, "Well, my
wife is into this stuff and I used to
laugh at her.
Um but she tells me it has to do with
willing something to happen before the
game." And they said, "Well, what do you
mean?" And he said, "Well, she
encourages me to take these little
amulets and stuff with me and I set up a
little altar in the locker room where
I've got pictures of my family and I've
got these amulets and stuff." And he
said,
"She tells me before the game whether
the game is won or lost."
She's predicted it with incredible
accuracy many years in a row. Like this
year you guys will go to the Super Bowl,
next year you will not. Like it happens
that way. But do you know what I saw in
the one interview? He said she is a
witch.
That's right. That's right. And you're
like, Yeah.
I mean, if you had said that 20 years
ago, they would have been like protest,
everybody would have been, you know,
um protesting or not supporting him. And
now he's saying, "Hey, my wife's a
witch, but we're winning." And people
laugh and smile about it. Come a long
way since Salem, haven't we? Yes, we
have. And not saying we don't want to
burn anybody. No, no, no. That was
extreme and over the
But you know what's scary?
In the Old Covenant, it said witches
would be stoned or burned. You know,
different There was different penalties.
Do you know the penalties haven't
changed?
You look at what happens at the lake of
fire.
All of those that have been involved in
sorcery and witchcraft, Revelation says,
are going to burn.
You know, it talks about the fact that
plagues are going to fall on the wicked
and there's going to be hailstones the
size of, you know, 60 to 75 lb.
They're going to be stoned. It's not our
place to do it now. Our place is because
we're living under a great period of
grace to love people and try to win
them. But everyone that rejects the
offer that God has given them of love
and mercy and eternal life through his
son,
they don't have a good future. It's wild
to see so much of our culture really
embracing these concepts and now that
we've kind of talked about this a couple
of times, I notice it everywhere. You
know, you see them in the like the
little magazines that they stands in the
grocery stores and things and it's just
like, "Wow, dude, they're putting this
everywhere."
Don't you think part of the reason
they're shifting and this paradigm shift
is taking place in our culture
is because most people, not all, but
most people have only been acquainted
with a powerless and quite often false
presentation of Christianity. That's
true. Where they've gotten acquainted
with doctrines and ideas, creeds,
ideologies, uh
traditions, rituals, ceremonies,
denominationalism,
uh which isn't always bad, but
denominationalism
and and that's the emphasis, not a
personal encounter with the Lord Jesus
Christ. And if we had kept it on that,
Amen. I don't think we would have lost
our culture.
And when I say we, I'm talking about
generation after generation. That's
right. I agree.
we have many forms of godliness, but we
deny the power. Here's another one,
Mindfulness an Everyday Guide, The
Science of Happiness in a Hectic World.
Now, it's Look at Look at the pose.
She's in the lotus pose for yoga, but
look at her fingers. She's doing exactly
what you showed. Actually, it's
different. It's different. She's
touching the third finger. The third
finger. Okay, that's what we did in the
What does that stand That's what we did
in the Buddhist. I do not remember what
the I don't either. what the god was,
but I know that when you connect those
fingers, it's supposed to help complete
a circuit of the energy the chi within
the body. That's what they teach.
Keith, do you remember
anything specific on that one? In the
last program we did,
I mentioned that when you put your
fingers like this, the four finger means
the Atman, which is the soul in Hindu
theology, and the thumb means Brahman,
which is the over soul, the impersonal
cosmic force and it A pantheistic god.
You don't refer to Brahman as he, you
refer to Brahman as it. It's the life
force in everything. But, when you do
that, you're asking It's an invocation.
You're asking Brahman to manifest within
you.
Right. Uh
In other words, to become fully aware
and conscious that you are God. Which is
exactly what Morgan Freeman was trying
to persuade people.
And the snake in the garden.
Here's another one, Yoga Journal, The
Power of Mindfulness, 25 Practices for
Joy and Balance. So, I mean Is she doing
the same No, she's doing the first
finger.
She's doing two finger. No. No, is she
doing She's doing the four finger, yeah.
But, she's doing a little differently.
Here's Newsweek.
Um I mean, Newsweek special edition,
mindfulness, reinvent yourself, live in
the moment.
You know, she reminds me with her
clasped hands like this of the Namaste
greeting. Yes. And
Namaste, the god in me
Uh salutes the god in
Yeah, salutes the god in you. So, it's a
recognition of our common divinity. That
And that's terrifying.
And I know people who run
Christian yoga studios
that have no qualms about greeting
everyone who comes in the studio like
that, whether they're a committed
Christian or not. So, actually, they're
breaching
their relationship with the word of God
and introducing a whole new philosophy
by just making the Namaste greeting. And
you know, it's funny because the Bible
tells us what fellowship has light with
darkness. What communion has Belial with
Christ? I mean, there's there's no union
there. It doesn't mean that we can't
love people,
but I can't say I'm one with you, or I
can't acknowledge that, you know, the
god that's in you because the god that's
in the world is different than the god
that lives in us. Absolutely.
that's here, though, because we've just
talked about Christ in you, the hope of
glory, right? That's God in you, and yet
they're literally saying, "The god in me
is saluting the god in you," which is
what What God wants is he wants to dwell
inside of us. He wants to dwell in us as
as the sanctuary, right? It's his
rightful part in the frontal lobe. It's
kind of like I imagine, um you know,
when the children of Israel
um kept getting tripped up with Baal.
You know, I I I I did a little bit of
research on the god Baal, and it's
really interesting. Did you know that
that Baal was the one that they
attributed the rain and all the all the
things They made everything grow. He
made everything, right? So, that's kind
of like God, right? Did you know that he
actually fought for the people, and in
historical context, he fought a snake
god named Mot? I did not know that.
that he laid down his life and
sacrificed himself and was resurrected
back? I mean, look at these parallels.
So, I don't believe that when we read
those stories, we go, "Wow, in the
Bible, man, they're just way off course
over here." No, no, no, no, these things
are close to what the truth really is in
the same parallels, and I think that's
how so many of the of the Israelites
were duped to go worship them is because
it was just an easy trade. And look at
what this is doing, as well. And that's
like with Mithra.
Um Mithraism did the same thing. They
It's like their god And now we've got
people that are trapped. They've been
deceived by these pagan religions, and
they're saying, "Well, Christianity was
just copying all these older religions."
And you're like, "No, you don't
understand. Those were Satan's
counterfeit of the truth that was going
to come through Jesus Christ." This
might open up a can of worms, but
I'll ask anyway because I can imagine an
audience member thinking of something
like this.
When you're greeting people with Namaste
and you're putting your hands together,
is it more of the words that you're
speaking in the context, or is it the
putting in the hands together? Cuz I've
seen many cultures greet people like
this,
not necessarily saying Namaste. They're
just like, "Hello, you know, like, it's
nice nice to meet you." Or there's
something with this that
I don't know there's a mystical power to
that or associated with that or
pronounced to be associated with it.
Not attributed with some religious idea
or anything. Uh it's just a respectful
gesture for some people, but it's
actually revealing a world view point a
point of view
to others. Some people just do it
automatically and habitually, don't
really mean much by it. It's just I can
imagine people growing up like in
Thailand or something, and this is how
they they greet each other, you know,
like, "Hello," but they're not saying
Namaste or something with it. So, Well,
some
Yeah, on that note, what's the religious
background for Thailand?
Buddhist.
So, I I I wonder, then, too, if it's
like um the whole yoga thing. I I don't
think the devil And I think it was maybe
you that brought this up, or was one of
you guys maybe uh he cannot trademark
the the um you know, a stretch down to
the ground, right? So, if you are like
doing a push-up, which is a similar
position in in yoga,
just because you're in a push-up form
doesn't necessarily mean that all of a
sudden you're doing yoga. But, it's when
you take that and you lay it in the
context of yoga, just like the Ouija
boards. Spelling is not a bad thing, but
now you put a magnifying glass and you
put it in that context, and you're
spelling things out has a whole
different meaning to it. So, I imagine
that's kind of like this.
So, I just don't want people to get the
like the wrong idea, like, "Oh, man,
I've been greeting people this way my
whole life, you know, putting my hands
together." Like, is that evil? Is there
something wrong with that? They're
totally going to burn. Not necessarily.
You know.
It's the context that you're putting it
It does, but it also, for me, and I
found this out.
We have to go back and examine
from the word. And And there's a a verse
in the Bible, I believe it's in Hosea,
it says, "My people are destroyed for Or
it's either Hosea, or maybe Hosea 4.
It says, "My people are destroyed for
lack of knowledge." It means the devil
is leading them.
I Listen, I went to church every single
week. Went to Bible study. I had family
worship with my family every single
evening.
Read my Bible.
Six days a week, I was worshipping
another god because I was doing
something that was against what his word
tells me to do.
I trained six days a week, 8 to 12 hours
a day in martial arts and tai chi and
chi gong. And one day a week and a
couple hours throughout the week, I gave
everything else to the Lord. God is
saying,
"If you have got a relationship with me
and there's something in your life, ask
me constantly." Lord, the people of
Israel, when they came out of Babylon,
they had been living in Babylon for 70
years. And you know what the first thing
God did? He helped them to find the book
of the law, Moses' first five books that
were written in the Bible. Right. He
helped You know what they did? They were
so excited that they had found God's
instructions for how to live again. And
you know what's amazing to me when you
read it in Ezra and Nehemiah, which are
two of my favorite books in the Old
Testament, it says that they were so
excited about finding this that someone,
one of the priests, stood up and and
read it. Might have been Ezra. And then,
while he was reading, cuz you know,
there's thousands there. They couldn't
all hear his voice necessarily. He had
other priests under him that helped the
people understand what he was reading.
And you know what the people did? It
says they stood half the day in the rain
listening to God's instructions for how
to live.
And they wept. And I thought, "Why were
they weeping?" Because they realized,
"Man, I've been living I've been raising
my children wrong. I've been doing
things that were against God's will."
And they wept. So, they listened for
half of the day, and then it says they
confessed for the other half. And after
that repentance, it was like God was
like, "Get up off your knees. It's time
to rejoice now. You've asked for
forgiveness. Accept what I've done, you
know, for you,
and and move forward in righteousness."
Well, that's where you have that
powerful script scripture that's quoted
so often, Nehemiah 8:10,
where he said, "Sorrow not." Ezra waved
his hands over all these people
groveling in the dirt and groaning and
weeping and travailing. And he said,
"Sorrow not. Grieve not. This day is
holy unto the Lord, for the joy of the
Lord is your strength." Amen.
is God's joy? God's joy is not looking
back and digging up the dirt from the
past. He wants to cover that and get rid
of that if we'll cooperate. Amen.
His joy is taking us into the future
because you can't change the past by
grieving over it, but you can change the
future by having a faith-filled,
joy-filled attitude as you walk toward
the future.
Amen. That's a beautiful point. This was
one that I found at the health food
store that I go to. And this this
terrified me. All these things, Newsweek
and Mindful, and you're like, "Yeah, but
none of that attaches it to Buddhism."
Look at this one. This is a Buddhist
magazine, and look at the name of the
magazine. Lions Roar. The Bible says
Does not Satan go about as a roaring
lion? And I thought,
he is right there in front of us. Wow.
And they're And And they're saying it.
And it says, "The Buddhist Guide to
Mindfulness." Wow. The Lions Roar.
Now, in one of our earlier programs, we
talked about the fact that God dwells
inside of us through his word.
So, Satan gets inside of us
one of the primary ways through his
words.
Mhm. Through his his spirits. That's
right.
Mhm. I'm going to show you from Buddhist
another way. This is one of the ways
that I learned. It was called mushin.
In Buddhism, uh especially in Aikido and
in uh Kodokan Judo and in Samurai, they
had something that they called mushin.
Um
In in Zen, there is a state of being
referred to as mushin, which is said to
be a mental state into which very highly
trained martial artists are said to
enter during combat.
They also practice this mental state
during everyday activities.
The term is shortened from mushin to
shin, which is a Zen expression meaning
the mind of no mind. It also is referred
to as the state of no mindedness.
That is a mind that is not fixed or
occupied by thought or emotion and thus
open to everything. The grand master I
began training under, his primary style
was was kung fu.
And he told us after we had reached a a
high rank level, which was like an
initiated level, not black belt, you
know, yet,
but he told the whole class that was
there,
he said,
"For you to really know how to fight,"
"You cannot think during the fight.
Because if you're trying to think like a
beginner does, 'Oh no, they threw a
right cross. What was that block?' You
know, it's too late. You're already
hit." He said, "You have to get to the
point." And I know you probably had the
same thing, Keith.
You had to get to the point where there
was no thought, where you reacted by
instinct.
And what terrified me about that was is
if it's instinct,
you know, I take little Johnny and Susie
and we'll we'll choose the children as
examples. I take them, I'm a
Christian parent, I take them to their
karate class or kung fu class,
and they go in there and for 3 hours a
week,
right punch comes, block, counter. Right
punch comes, block, counter. Right punch
comes, over and over and over again,
week after week, month after month, year
after year. They go to church for 2
hours a week and Jesus says, "Turn the
other cheek."
2 hours a week, but yet they're
physically practicing the opposite for
hours and years.
Mhm.
Now, little Johnny or Susie's at school.
A bully comes up or somebody that's
making fun of them and and forgive me
for this, Mike, but they come up and
they push them.
Jesus said, I'm going to finish.
block, counter. Because they practiced
it.
The grand master told me, and I'll never
forget this. This was the first one I
trained under and I was with him for 20
years. He said, "I remember when I was
working at this factory.
One night it was late and he said, I
everybody there knew about my martial
arts. And he said, 'A lot of them, they
wanted to challenge you. They wanted to
find out, does this really work?' And he
said, 'One night I was walking down this
long hall and it was like three or four
stories tall inside this building in
this factory.' And he said it was dark.
And he said, 'One of those men that
didn't like me stepped out from behind
me, probably 20 or 30 feet away,
and stepped out and he was like, "I'm
going to get him. There's nothing he'll
see. He won't even see this coming.
Let's see how how good he really is."
And he took a big metal wrench. I'm
talking about something that weighed
probably 10 lb. Mhm. He took it and
flung it straight towards him. And the
grand master told me, "I'm walking
along." And he said, "I didn't even know
it was coming." He said, "All of a
sudden I went boom and I grabbed it."
And I just kept right on walking.
And I was like, "Wow." And do you know
there was a movie that came out a couple
of years ago with Nick Nolte and um
Oh, it was based on the
Jonathan Livingston Seagull book. But he
did the exact same thing.
You know, a guy threw a wrench and he
was there working, he went boom and
caught it. And people go, "Oh man, that
would be so cool to do that." It's not
cool because it's the demon that's
inside you that sees it coming.
And I did not know that until after I
had made like disciple level, which was
a fifth degree or fifth dan. And I
remember I got out there. I used to
struggle with with fighting one of these
guys that was going for black belt. It
was a battle.
And one night we were in there and there
was two of these guys that were fighting
for their black belt and the grand
master was sitting beside me and he was
like, "Don't you wish you could be out
there again, Eric?" Cuz he wouldn't let
me fight any of them anymore because I
was just like, you know,
I would hurt them rather than suffer
loss.
And I looked at him I said, "Let me
fight both of them right now."
And he looked in my eyes and I it was
not me saying that. The words were going
through my head,
but I voiced it because I thought it was
my mind. But another mind was in there.
And I looked at him I said, "Let me get
out there with both of them right now."
And he was like, cuz he remembered one
of those men was the one I had to defeat
to make black. And he weighed not
I was 170, he weighed 285 lb.
He outweighed me by 100 lb. Mhm.
And now I said, "I'll get out there with
both of these guys." Mhm. And I got out
there and in a a minute and a half, they
both were on the ground. But it was not
me. Either one of them guys could smack
me now and I would hit the floor. I
mean, it was not me doing it. But that's
what happens when you get out there. And
they were throwing kicks and punches and
I remember it was like everything just
slowed down. I was standing there and it
was like my hand would go down and I was
not moving my hand. And then I would
feel that it was blocking a kick or my
hand would go over here and I didn't
even realize a punch was being thrown.
Because you had an empty mind.
And what that means is
I took God out of his rightful place and
something else took his place.
It's not an empty mind.
It will the mind cannot be empty. It's
either filled with one or it's filled
with the other. But the whole goal of
Yes.
of mindfulness is to empty your mind.
Well, in mushin, it was to empty it.
Mindfulness is a a subtle change in
that. Yes, sir. I I I think it's kind of
also interesting that um you know, what
what if we look at the other side of
this this argument and say that you
know, if if every time you were tempted,
you just dropped down on your knees and
you started praying to God.
That was your that was your go-to
reaction,
how would that change? You know, you
would strengthen that every time.
Something gets thrown at you, Lord, help
me. You know what I mean? Lord, help me.
And it's all of a sudden you just kind
of train yourself. I mean, that that's
what I think the devil's doing is he's
perverting these natural things that we
have. We have we have so many um
addictions uh you you call them, you
know, like habits, but we need to come
home every day. We need to eat every
day. We need to exercise. You know, we
need to do these things, right? So, the
human body needs to do this repetitive
thing action over here, but the devil
just goes, "You know what? I'm going to
make them have this repetitive action
over here so that they're just reacting
and not thinking." Something that that
has helped me personally in that area, I
found that when I was faced with
temptation,
often I didn't want to get on my knees
because it was a battle.
But what I realized is the reason that
there was a battle happening was because
I was still Eric was still very much
alive.
Eric wanted to do such and such,
but Eric was still alive. But the Bible
says, "Reckon yourself also to be dead
indeed unto sin." So, what I have to do
is instead of waiting until I'm faced
with temptation and then going, "Man, I
really I know I should get on my knees.
No, I'm not going to get on my knees.
I'm just going to confront this."
Now I'm finding I have to get up in the
morning, first thing in the morning, and
get on my knees and the very first thing
I've got to say, "My body, my heart, my
mind is yours. I surrender to you.
Let this mind be in me." And and then
throughout the rest of the day when the
temptation comes,
Christ says, "This is mine." Mhm. Eric,
I'll get on my knees cuz Christ won the
victory over that temptation. So, it's
him now that is helping me to do what I
would struggle to do.
Mhm.
One of the Japanese uh masters, and
forgive me if I don't get his name
exactly right, uh Masatoshi Nakayama,
uh a man that I knew number of years
ago, uh Vito Rallo, which I think you
guys have done some some work with him.
He trained under Nakayama.
And he now that's all he does is help
people to get free.
But listen to what he said.
It is in this highest state that we just
talked about, mushin,
the essence that is common to the
martial arts and ways of Japan that I
would next explain.
In short, the Zen priest says that the
mind, if placed nowhere, is everywhere.
The concept reflects Buddhism's
abhorrence of attachment and bonds.
Such such antipathy
antipathy is based on the concept of
what they call the void, being no
minded, the void.
Expect depression, expect suicidal
thoughts, expect sometimes to have waves
of insanity and madness. You might feel
like you're losing your mind and you
actually have this weird energy moving
through you and you start to behave as
though your body is being controlled by
a puppet master. Your body is just
moving on its own and you have no idea
what's controlling you. It's almost like
you've been possessed. Wow.
Now that that is a new age teacher. He
teaches all kinds of that stuff that
lies in darkness, deception. And he's
all over YouTube.
But he has a whole series on
mindfulness. But he talks in there about
the fact of
there's a danger like you talked about
with yoga and Kundalini.
the gurus emphasized it. Yeah, so he's
saying but he he comes down and he's
like it's almost like being possessed
and I was like
it's coming right out of their mouth.
It felt like an entity entered you, you
know, like
Yes.
Now listen to what this lady says. This
is Barbara O'Brien. Although meditation
has been marketed to the West as a
stress reduction technique, that was
never its purpose in Eastern spiritual
practices.
From its beginnings in the Vedic or
Hindu religious tradition of India,
people meditated to realize insight or
wisdom not to relax.
The spiritual meditative journey is not
always a blissful one. I suspect most of
us with long experience in a traditional
meditation practice have been through
some raw and edgy experiences with it.
That's what he was talking about.
Then she says occasionally someone will
have a meditation experience that is
disturbing or frightening or even
nightmarish.
That's what I want. I mean, really.
She said some people have taken to
calling these episodes a dark night of
the soul borrowing a phrase from the
Christian mystic and I I quote Christian
Saint John of the Cross because
he was not Christian.
In Buddhism, the English word void or
emptiness translates the Japanese word
ku
which derived from its original Sanskrit
or Hindu meaning which is this that we
should not be trapped by the difference
between good and evil.
Now what's amazing is that's Master
Nakayama. And even though he's Japanese,
which got their arts from the Chinese,
which got their arts from
the Hindu Hindu. Right. Well, Buddhism
sprang out of Hinduism. That's right.
They uh
they don't emphasize that but it's true.
Uh
Um Buddha himself was
um rebelling against a lot of what
Hinduism taught like the multiple
deities Mhm. and uh the caste system
Yes, I know.
because by the caste system Buddha was
on a lower level.
And so anyway Mhm. They are and that
they are very related. And that's
interesting cuz you know, like in the
Dragon Revealed part one, that was like
the eye-opening moment for me when I
walked into that grandmaster's house.
I'd never been to his house before and
there were these huge murals of Hindu
deities and I was like
what does what does Hinduism have to do
with Shaolin? Mhm. And you know, and it
was like here I'd been in this for all
this time and didn't have any idea. And
this was interesting because Keith
brought this out. Um
Musashi's book, The Book of Five Rings.
He says in Zen first comes technique,
practice so many times that it's
forgotten.
Then you begin to use it. Not the
techniques, the Zen.
Zen is no more I'm sorry. Let me rewind.
Then you begin to use it.
It is when you do not think about it
anymore that you do it so well. Zen is
no more than that but it is reaching
that state of consciousness that the
training is all about.
Yeah, there's a lot of business people
that actually read this book
uh for the principles that are in it,
you know, that especially the ones that
are wanting to be like really aggressive
and
and kind of take over cuz it comes with
that samurai mindset. Musashi was a a
samurai and he was he was very good.
Um so a lot of business people read it,
you know, for those what they can glean
in in that regard. What's uh what's our
military academy? West Point? Um The Art
of War
Yeah. was one of the that's like
required reading for them. And then they
they've taken that and the Book of Five
Rings and it's like they're applying it
as Keith said to a lot of different
fields.
So they're taking Buddhist and Hindu
principles
and applying them throughout all kinds
of life.
It's a a
a thread that is being woven throughout
our culture.
Now this is from Encyclopedia
Britannica. What is Zen people say or
Chan Buddhism?
We're going to give just a quick
definition. They say it is a religious
sect derived from the Sanskrit or Hindu
word dhyana
which means a process of meditation that
is used to achieve an awakening to the
Buddha nature.
Isn't that funny that it's God's whole
purpose is to give back to us that
divine nature that was lost
and that's what they're trying to do.
But putting it in different terminology.
And different interpretations
altogether. That's exactly right.
Buddha taught
a number of doctrines that are the
foundation of Buddhism that would be
included under that banner of being
awakened to the Buddha nature. One thing
uh you have to come to the conclusion of
is that nothing is permanent. That's
right. And so you have to detach
yourself from the world and from things
and from good and from evil and not to
be affected by any of it because none of
it's permanent anyway. Which is wrong.
Because there are permanent outcomes to
this life and there is a permanent
existence. Buddha taught that there's no
such thing as the soul. There's a a a
I think the best way to put it in
English is an unconscious disposition
that passes from one incarnation to the
next but it's not a soul of sorts. And
he also taught that it's wrong to
believe that your soul can have a
everlasting existence in heaven. Mhm.
That that is uh less than being
awakened. You're trapped inside of
falsehood religiously if you believe
that. And yet there's books out like
Buddha and Jesus I I know.
brothers
but their doctrine doesn't connect, it
disconnects because Jesus taught you do
have a soul and Jesus taught that you
will live permanently and that there
will be a permanent new creation.
Amen.
So Buddha was wrong. Some will wake to
everlasting life and some awake to
everlasting destruction.
Right.
And it's funny because Buddha's dead and
Christ is alive.
Right. Hallelujah. And Buddha died of
food poisoning, they say, at the age of
and is still in the grave or does.
Yeah. And Jesus died a much worse death
than food poisoning and he came out of
the grave and said I'm alive
forevermore.
Here's another
uh magazine. It it's called The Buddhist
Guide to Mindfulness. I'm just showing
you these and it's published, it's a
special edition from Lion's Roar. Um it
says uncovering the spiritual roots of
mindfulness meditation
and deep to and deepening your practice.
So this is being heavily promoted right
now. Mike, did you have something?
Well, I was just going to mention that
being a mindful person
depends on embracing other aspects of
Buddhism. Yes. Because you can't be
mindful unless you accept the four noble
truths
and the eightfold path.
And the four noble truths, and I'll do
it very succinctly
number one, life is full of suffering
which is dukkha
uh which means imperfection, emptiness
or suffering. Number two, the cause of
suffering is desire. Desiring to have a
good life, desiring to have possessions,
desiring to have fulfillment in marriage
or whatever. Cause of suffering is
desire for things like existence,
prosperity, achievement and pleasure.
The only way to overcome suffering is to
overcome desire.
And this is accomplished by following
the eightfold path. That's number four.
So that's the four noble truths. The
eightfold path is right knowledge, right
thought, right speech, right conduct,
right livelihood, right effort, right
mindfulness, right mindfulness and right
meditation.
That all sounds really good unless you
know the interpretation of right
knowledge. And that includes believing
what Buddha believed and
much of what he believed was completely
wrong. Yeah. Isn't isn't that
interesting that that even here they are
showing their hand with saying suffering
comes from desire, right? Well, way back
in the Garden of Eden, isn't that what
the devil was trying to entice her with
was the desires of being like XYZ or
whatever and she took partook of that
and then this is just how the devil
works. He's going to like make you fall
and then he's going to go, here's here's
the real reason why you fell and here's
how I have to fix it and it's just
slightly off.
And you know the Bible encourages us to
desire good things.
Right. Right. I mean like like Kate is
married, I'm married, I mean all of us
are married.
Even God gives you the
desires of your heart. He plants those
desires in you and then fulfills those
desires. The term Chan or Zen originates
from the Sanskrit or Hindu word Dhyana
which literally means meditation.
According to Buddhist and Hindu
teaching, the practice of Dhyana or
meditation, and forgive me if I'm
mispronouncing that, if you see that,
you know, correct me.
Okay.
Because you know the the Hindu words
better than I would ever imagine.
It says this form or practice of
meditation is used to achieve an altered
state of consciousness called Samadhi.
That's correct.
Or that's the correct pronunciation,
it's not a correct belief.
Yes. Yes.
Now listen to this. Samadhi
is this is the literal interpretation
intense concentration achieved through
meditation at which point a union with
the divine is said to be achieved.
And they they could call that Brahma or
the cosmos.
the Hindu perspective, not the Buddhist
perspective.
Right.
So but yeah, but there's different names
for it. Some of it will call it like
Oprah talks about the universe, you
know, connect with the cosmos or with
the universe or Eckhart Tolle or any of
these different variations, but all of
it, no matter how slight the variation,
is leading us away from Christ.
Yeah, because none of these things can
take you into real relationship with
God. Amen.
They can alter your consciousness, they
can change your mindset, and you may
think it's for the good, but you're left
with a life that still lacks the
fundamental need, and that's to come
back into union with God.
Amen. It cannot be achieved except
through John 14:6. I am the way, the
truth, and the life, and no one comes to
the Father but by me.
Amen.
Jesus was either insane, an egomaniac,
or he was who he said he was, the only
door to eternity. And I subscribe
absolutely to the latter. Amen.
Amen.
Okay, we've got a couple of verses here
that we want to close with. And listen
to what this All of this, we saw what
mindfulness, where it leads. We took you
from the beginning step of, oh no, it's
just about peace and relaxation, and
we're showing you that this is where the
path goes.
Now listen to what Christ said. This is
what Satan was trying to counterfeit or
is trying to counterfeit. These words
spake Jesus and lifted up his eyes to
heaven and said, Father,
I pray that they all might be one as
thou, Father, art in me
and I in thee, that they also may be one
in us,
so that the world may believe that thou
hast sent me. Do you know all the way
back in Psalm 107 verse, I think it was
verse 19 and 20, he says, he sent his
word and healed them and delivered them
from their destructions.
When we become one with Christ and one
with God, his life is manifest in our
mortal flesh, the world goes, God really
did what he said he was going to do.
Yes. Now I've got a couple of really
really good quotes from an old Christian
writer I want I want you to to hear.
Listen to this.
The moment the sinner lays hold on
Christ by faith, that moment their sins
are no longer upon them.
I believe you did what you said you did,
that you laid all of my iniquities on
Jesus at Calvary, Isaiah 53.
The moment they lay hold on Christ by
faith,
that moment their sins are no longer
upon them.
For Christ stands in the sinner's place.
That's in your place and in my place.
He stands in our place
and he declares, I have borne your guilt
and my guilt. I have been punished for
your transgressions and my
transgressions. I have taken their sins
and I have put my righteousness upon
them. Righteousness means holiness and
purity and and perfection. Wow. Christ
never sinned.
That's the life he wants to give to you.
Have you ever woke up or have you ever
had a day where you fell to a temptation
and for the next week you struggled with
guilt?
Christ never woke up and felt guilty. He
never had a day where he wondered if his
father still loved him.
That's the peace that he can give to you
today. He says, my peace give I unto
you. Let not your heart be troubled,
neither be afraid.
I have overcome the world. You believe
in God, believe also in me. I am the
word of God that was made flesh.
I have taken your sins and put my
righteousness upon you.
In Christ,
the sinner stands guiltless before the
law of God. Amen. That one word should
catch your attention. Guiltless does not
mean just forgiven.
Because I can break the speed limit, I'm
doing 190, and I get a $500 ticket, and
I go to get a job at UPS, and they say,
we need to know if you've got a perfect
record. I say, yes.
I don't know any tickets. I mean every I
got and they come back and they go, we
can't give you the job, you lied. And
I'm like, why? And they say, 10 years
ago you were pulled over and you were
doing 190 in a 65. And I'm like, yeah,
but it was forgiven. The judge pardoned
it. And they go, it doesn't matter, you
still did it. You're still guilty.
Christ never sinned.
If he takes your life from you today, he
says, is the day of salvation, and gives
his life to you by faith,
his guiltlessness and purity and
righteousness is yours.
Amen.
It is not now the work of the sinner to
make peace with God, but to accept
Christ as his peace and righteousness.
And it says that in Ephesians
chapter 1 and chapter 2.
For thus man becomes one with Christ and
one with God.
There is no way which they just quote
what you said, John 14:6. There is no
way by which the heart may be made holy
save through faith in Jesus Christ.
Hallelujah.
We'll close with Proverbs chapter 4.
The Lord says to each of us, speaking to
you and I, and when you read this, read
your name into the promises.
He says, my son, my daughter,
attend to my words. I love it. Incline
thine ear to my sayings. That means my
teaching, my instructions.
Let them not depart from your eyes and
keep them in the midst of your heart.
For they are life unto those that find
them, and they are health to all our
flesh.
Hallelujah. Amen. Eric, can I add one
thing?
You Yes, sir. A Christian response to
mindfulness. Mindfulness is supposed to
make you more successful. Mhm.
Mindfulness is supposed to make you more
fulfilled.
purposeful in the way you do things
because you're focused, you're not
distracted by thinking about the past or
the future, etc. Mhm. But I think that
there is a biblical response to that.
Amen. How I should approach every
activity of every day, even the mundane
things. Amen.
Like I'm painting my porch in the
backyard right now or washing dishes or
whatever. It says, whatever, this is By
the way, this is Colossians chapter
3 verse 17, I believe. Whatever you do
in word or deed, do all in the name of
the Lord Jesus giving thanks to God the
Father through him. And another
scripture says that whatever you do,
even work, even normal work, do it as
unto the Lord and not unto man. So you
are focused and you are connecting with
the moment and doing your best, reaching
for excellence because you're not
distracted, but it's all an act of
worship toward God. And of course
Buddhism doesn't have a belief in God.
So this takes mindfulness to the next
level if you want to look at it.
To the truth. I mean it leaves the
deception behind, but then it's not just
being focused on the moment, it's being
focused on God.
And that's what we need. And you know
what's cool? That I thought you were
about to read it. He also says, be
anxious for nothing. Mhm. But in
everything with prayer and thanksgiving,
let your request be made known to God.
Absolutely. So that's the only way you
can pray without ceasing. And we can't
lose that way.
some people have almost gone bananas
trying to pray without ceasing,
muttering prayers all day long. It
doesn't mean to actually always be
talking constantly, know, but have a
attitude that everything I do is sacred.
Everything I do is a sacrament in a
sense of commitment
of my ways. In all your ways acknowledge
him. That's the best way of saying it.
Amen. Most people, I think, get into
Buddhism or whatever because they want
to be, you know,
mindful of their citizenship to others
and stuff like, you know, that that just
that just kind of I'm doing this and
it's making me calm and I'm going to,
you know, give everybody a better
existence and all this kind of stuff.
But, yeah, what you're saying is so
true. It's like if everything that you
do, you had an eternal focus. How does
this fit into my paradigm?
You know, then you can understand how
somebody like Joseph would would would
sold into slavery by his brothers, so
many times kicked down, you know, lied
about and all sorts of stuff. And he
literally did the best job he could. He
went to prison, swept that prison so
clean that the prison guard made him the
master over all And I guarantee it
wasn't because he was a Buddhist
practicing mindfulness. Amen.
a Jew that was doing Well,
he He wasn't a Jew yet because Jews came
in later on, the offspring of Judah.
But, um
he he was a Hebrew. He was an Israelite
that believed in consecrating his life
and everything he did as an act of
worship to God. Amen. We really
appreciate y'all spending this time with
us. And we pray that this second part
has been a blessing as much as the first
part cuz we don't want to leave people
in darkness.
Um the Bible tells us to expose the
works of darkness, but if all we do is
expose the darkness without revealing
the light and the truth, it's a waste of
time. Um so, please contact Little Light
Studios, contact us. We've got videos,
we've got other information. Uh Brother
Mike Shreve has got some tremendous
resources available. All of that will be
at the bottom of this link. And uh pray
that the Lord will bless you and keep
you. And as you're opening His word, our
greatest prayer is as you read it out
loud and you read your name into those
words,
that you will hear God's voice speaking
to you through His word. That you will
have a living connection with Him, not
just a theoretical head knowledge about
Bible truth.
That's our prayer. We We thank you for
your prayers and for your support. Um
may the Lord bless and keep you and your
family this week.